Maja's on the line in Boston
Massachusetts is it magic that's my date
say again no change
okay I'll never make it how can I help
hi I was calling because I am in a
relationship with someone who's very
money depending and I wanted to know if
I should get rid of the relationship
okay
so money dependent so he lives off of
you well um yeah like everything he
wants me to pay for everything and stuff
like that yeah how long you been dating
a year and two months so what's the
weirdest things you paid for his mom
like away his mom's closet right rent he
asked you to pay his mother's rent yeah
because his mom doesn't work or anything
she want cheese um disability and how
old is this person this guy 20 he's 20
mm-hmm and hold are you making okay and
what do you make a year I am a real
estate agent so I make oh it's very very
present I would pay about like 20 what
do you make would you pay taxes on last
year when you do your taxes for 2016
where you were going to show your income
to be um five twenty-five thousand and
how much does he like he doesn't make
anything on me why um because the
situation is fees and calculated so he
doesn't make like so he like it doesn't
work he's been across the road for a
while for a while so you're dating was
were you're dating him when he became
incarcerated you started dating him
after he went to jail before
mm-hmm okay when is he supposed to get
out of jail anyway
okay
and so is this guy I'm going to be a
productive citizen then or is he going
to continue to be a character he he says
so but I don't I don't believe it okay
so you're telling me not only is he
financially irresponsible he's generally
a character yes okay you have any
brothers or sisters I do they're all out
of the house well okay and how old are
they a young Jamie yes I'm the youngest
I have four brothers okay well your
brother will show you I'll talk you
don't talk you're right no I do but I
don't deserve them about is your dad and
is your dad in your life he's in another
street okay but is he relationally in
your life yeah I mean you have a good
relationship with him yeah if you were
to sit down over a cup of coffee with
your dad what would he tell you to do Oh
leave yeah without without up he
wouldn't blink would he let you know a
little buddy yeah and you're his
daughter aren't you yeah so yeah you
already know what you're supposed to do
because if you had a little sister that
was doing this you would bunk her on the
head absolutely he would say little sis
run off from the loser run from the
loser as fast as you can run that's what
you would tell your little sister
wouldn't you absolutely did you just
need me to say it out loud because you
were already thinking it I really fit
okay the word is run are you in okay
uh-huh
thank you for calling in kiddo open
phones at triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 you got
to get old to be able to do that call
you can't do that call when you're 25 I
can do it I'm 56 okay I can do that call
I got girls older than her oh my
goodness I can a guy go to jail and turn
his life around yeah but until he does
he's not marriage material after he
turns his life around not when he talks
about it and no you don't go paying his
stuff for him this guy's a parasite
today can he is he always going to be a
parasite well that's up to him he can
decide to change his life and
repent and turn his life around that'd
be wonderful hope he does but until he
does he's not marriage material run hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]